ضبطيات بالملايين بين يوم واخر تشهدها
منافذ السعوديه اخرها ضبط نحو نصف مليون
حبه كبتاجون في ميناء ضبا في تبوك وخلال
شهر مايو الجاري ايضا ضبطت الحمله التي
تنفذها وزاره الداخليه ومديريه مكافحه
المخدرات ملايين الحبات من الكبتاجون
واطنان من الحشيش
فضلا عن ضبط عدد من المروجين لماده الشكوك
وزير الداخليه السعوديه الامير عبد العزيز
بن سعود بن نايف اكد قبل ايام ان الحمله
لن تتوقف حتى تحقيق كامل اهدافها
ونتوقف الان مع ابرزقيات المخدرات التي
شهدها شهر مايو جاري في عدد من المنافذ
والمدن السعوديه
[موسيقى]
في استديوهاتنا من الرياض ينضم الينا سفير
المشروع السعودي للوقايه من المخدرات
نبراز الفنان فايز المالكي يا علي خالد
يعطيك العافيه
في قناه العربيه القناه الام اللي تقدم كل
شيء مصداقيه ويا رب اكون ضيف خفيف عليكم
دايما ابو راكان يبرز اسمك كواحد من اهم
الرواد والمؤثرين والبارزين في المشاريع
الخيريه والانسانيه ومع انطلاق الحمله كان
لك ايضا فيديو كان مؤثر تناقلته يمكن كل
المواقع كل المساحات كل وكالات الانباء
ظهرت فيها بشكل مختلف ابو راكان يعني قدمت
رساله كانت مؤثره في في في نبره صوتك في
في طريقه عرضك ايضا وسط اكوام من المخدرات
اللي شفناها والحبوب
من الحملات المكافحه المخدرات لكن ليش
ظهرت بهذه الصوره وش اللي شفته في هذه
الحمله مختلف عن حملات سابقه شارك فيها
والله خالد وانا اخوك اللي صورته ثمانيه
مليون و250 الف حبه يعني اعتمدوا 50 مليون
هذا
وانتشرت على الرياض دمرت الرياض كلها يا
اخي انا عندي اطفال عندي بنات عندي اقارب
عندي احبه لو طاحت فيهم الحبوب هذي دمرت
مستقبلهم انتم قبل شوي تعرضون ما شاء الله
تبارك الله نشر مع رواد الفضاء حنا واصلين
الفضاء ما شاء الله تبارك الله يتكلمون
انه على الالوان تكلمنا عن رواد الفضاء
اللي موجودين بالله لو وصل لها الاطفال
لها النشر اليوم التطبيقات منتشره اليوم
الاماكن التي توصلكم تجيكم من امريكا تجي
لحد بيتك فبالتالي احنا شعب مستهدف دليفري
اي طبعا احنا شفت انا شفت شيء الحقيقه من
خلال قناتكم اوجه شكر لوزير الداخليه
والرجال مكافحه والجمارك نشوف اشياء عظيمه
جدا تقبض عليها انا سته كيلو يقول لي
الضابط السته كيلو هذا الشبوب لو توزعت
على الرياض دمرتها على الرياض اذا كان
الوصل
سته كيلو ويضاف عليها المكونات
حقتهمون الشباب والزياره الواحده تخليك
تدمن يعني ما في تراجع مو تقول والله بجرب
بجرب سيجاره وبعدين لا خلاص من اول مره من
اول مره فبالتالي لازم نخاف لازم نتحمس
التلقائيه والتقليديه العاديه اللي كنا
اول شيء التقليد المخدرات هذاك المخدرات
ضايعه ما عاد تنفع الان انت تقصد الرسائل
هذه يا جماعه شوفوا بعينكم شوفوا بام
عينكم هذا المخدرات هذا الهلاك هذا الضياع
هذا ولا ما عاد ينفع انا ممكن اجي اصوره
المخدرات شكرا لك ما حد يسب لكن اعتقد انه
بعد اللي صورناه وهذا ما هو تقرير في جوده
الاخرين لكن الرساله وصلت
الطفل الصغير شايف فايز المالكي وش قاعد
يسوي ويخاف ويستوعب ويستدرك انه لا في شيء
غلط جدا بالتالي الله يحفظها بعد تصويرك
لهالمقطع ابو شمس سعيد جدا للمقطع هذا
مشاهداته فوق 350 مليون هذا بس في
الحسابات اللي انا اتابعها
كثير خالد
انه انا عندي واحد من عيالي بس يا اخي انا
خايف ابلغ ثم يمسكونه وننفضح لا ما في
فضيحه اليوم وزاره الداخليه وعلى الامير
عبد العزيز بن سعود بن نايف والعاملين في
مكافحه المخدرات وفي مستشفى الامل للوقايه
ولا العلاج المدمنين ترى سريه تامه اذا
حسيت ان اخوك مدمن اذا الزوجه مدمنه اذا
الزوجه مدمنه اذا اي واحد يا اخي يبلغ فيه
ترى يمسكونه ويعالجونه ويخاطبون مقر عملاء
انه في مهمه من خلال وزاره الداخليه ما في
اي فضائح سريه تامه لكن احنا نسكت ليش
نسكت انت اذا سكت
انت عارف انه القضايا اللي قلتها للشبه
هذا كل يوم يقتل الاثنين ثلاثه لان ما
عندي خلاص ما عندي اي ما عنده اي تفكير
انه يرتك باي جريمه ويسوي اي شيء لانه
يمشي على الارض فساد خلاص ما في خوف ما في
احساس بالمسؤوليه يا اخي بعضهم صار
بعضهم قتلوا امه بعضهم قتل ابوه بعضهم
يجيب الرجال بيت العياله المساله كبرت جدا
وش اللي ينقص طيب في وجهه نظرك انت ابو
راكان هذه الحمله حتى تؤدي غرضها بشكل
المطلوب في وجود كبير يبذل ونشوف انه
المملكه من خلال هالجنه والمكلفه والحمله
ايضا اشبه بالحرب اللي تقيمها على
المخدرات في كل شارع نشوف يعني نقاط تفتيش
وغيرها والله يعطيهم العافيه لكن انت في
وجهه نظرك حتى تحقق هذه الحمله اهدافها في
شيء ناقص في شيء مطلوب اول شيء الشكل سموه
الامير محمد بن سلمان والعاد على تبني
هالح العظيمه والشكر موصول لكل رجال وزاره
الداخلي وعلى راسي وزير الداخليه لكن
خلونا نبعد عن الشيء التقليدي
التقليدي يا سيدي انه خلونا نصور انا طلب
اوجه الداخليه اترك الفائز المالكي يصور
لا تقول الكلمه هذه حساسه لا المشهد هذا
المخدرات
انا اعتقد انه رجال الجمارك ورجال مكافحه
مخدرات في كل المنافذ عندنا يمكن 14 منفذ
وعندنا المواني ترى في كل يوم ضبطيه وكل
يوم يمسكون بلاوي الدنيا فبالتالي خلونا
نصور خلونا نروح على الشباب والشابات
خلونا العالم ما ينفع يا جماعه امسك جوالي
واقول المخدرات هذاك هذا
وارميه هناك
حشيش اليوم مسكناه الشبو يا اخي انت ترى
على فكره الناس تتوقعون ان موقع السعوديه
فقط احنا شايفين في امريكا كيف سعره زومبي
يمشون
بعد لكن الحمد لله احنا ابتدينا من حيث
الاخرين الحرب عليها اليوم حتى الشوارع
خفت انا مفحطين واللي يجيك ماشي 200 يمشي
في الشارع ما تشوفه اليوم في ضبط واتمنى
الحمله مو بس شهر شهرين ثلاثه اتمنى على
مدار الايام على مدار السنين منظم بلدنا
ونحفظ شبابنا انت تطالب انه تفتح الابواب
لكم طبعا
في مختصين كبير جدا
اخصائيين نفسيين ممكن يقول لك اذا ولدك
انطوائي اذا ولدك والله يقعد في غرفه
بالعالم اذا ولدك متعاطي ما فيها شيء ما
فيها شيء
يعطيك ربي خالد جهد موفق
وجزاك الله خير على كل ما تكون في